it's the beginning of june two thousand
sixteen so as usual i'm going to do an
update video i want to talk about what
went on during the month of May and what
we've got coming up during this very
busy month of June a lot of stuff packed
in there as always I like to begin by
talking about three big things that I
want to highlight to bring to your
attention so the first one of those is a
class an online class on Plato's
symposium it's our second class that
we're offering with reason I oh I'm very
excited about this it's enrolling now
and begins on jun 19th and runs into
mid-july the second really big thing and
I think if you're in the Milwaukee area
or in the fox cities in Wisconsin or
even in the Greater Chicago area you're
probably going to want to come to this
because it's going to be a pretty big
event we're partnering with the
whitefish bay library to offer a lecture
and a tasting in which i'm going to talk
about the eight then that's eight not
four not five eight basic tastes of food
that we find discussed in the
Aristotelian tradition and then running
all the way into early modernity like i
said we're going to be doing a tasting
as well as a lecture and QA so it's
going to be quite a cool event the third
thing is even bigger so stoic on is an
annual conference in which the members
of the stoicism today project and a lot
of other big academics come in and give
workshops give talks about stoicism and
its applicability to modern life I'm
going to be presenting at stoic on and
i'll talk more about that later but what
i want to bring to your attention is in
in october when stoic on is going to run
i'm going to drive from here in
Milwaukee out to New York City and back
over the core
of two weeks this is our very first
attempt to have a circuit speaking tour
an old fashioned circuit tour so I've
already lined up a few events along the
way but most of our calendar is open so
I'll talk more about that but keep that
in the back of your mind if you're
interested if you're along the way and
you're interested in having me come
speak during those two weeks contact me
Greg at reason I oh and we'll get
talking about that because the calendar
is going to fill up fairly quickly all
right let's talk about the month of May
I had three different events occurred
during the month of May one of them
online and two of them at local
libraries here the one that was online
was my monthly half hour hagel Q&A
session that I hold every month sort of
a thank you for the generosity of my
patreon supporters and something for the
general public I continued our quarterly
series partnering with the Frank
Weinberg library on philosophers in the
midst of history the first one we did on
Aristotle this one was on Saint Anselm
so it was with medieval one the Normans
and the Catholic Church so a lot of cool
stuff got the video link to in the
description below so you can take a look
at that we also did we continue the the
monthly speculative fiction and
philosophy series this time focusing on
Isaac Asimov's foundation trilogy and a
little bit beyond that into some of the
other books so that was a really great
conversation that we had there again
videos linked to what else went on
during during May well we started our
first ever online course being offered
under the auspices of reason I out no
longer with any traditional colleges
universities no longer with these other
academic startups just us and we got a
really great response we have a number
of students enrolled in the class the
class is actually still
going on because it's being done in a
six-week version i front loaded an awful
lot of material at the beginning so I
think that next time I teach it it may
be an eight-week version so students
have a bit more time to work through
this but it has been an amazing
experience there's there's nothing like
actually after you've been taking sort
of marching orders from other people
doing something on your own when I say
on my own I don't mean totally on my own
my wife Andy Chaka has been absolutely
invaluable in helping me to organize
everything and doing all the backend
work that was a big thing that we did
over the course of this last month we
also in the stoicism today project have
been doing a lot of back-end work
getting ready for stoic on getting ready
for the stoic mindfulness and resiliency
training course that down robertson is
offering and getting ready for stoic
week 2016 so I'll talk more about the
stoic stuff in the June section because
I'm really excited about that I also did
quite a bit of academic coaching and
philosophical counseling and executive
coaching and even some tutoring as the
semester finished up I did a little bit
of blogging not quite so much as I would
have liked to as a matter of fact that's
a big disappointment find that I'm not
getting enough of that done spend a lot
of time doing academic writing getting
this this piece on an some and mercy and
justice in the prayers ready to go out
because the deadline is looming and it
should go out actually later today so
what about oh there's one other thing I
need to mention too I had a piece in
stoicism today as the editor I get to
every once in a while write a piece for
for the the blog and I started a series
which I'm going to be continuing and
eventually I'm going to write a book on
this short book to help people out ah
the series is on stoic philosophers and
anger this one in particular was on
epictetus and dealing with other
people's anger
I'm going to be having a follow up
coming up which will be about dealing
with your own anger according to
Epictetus what else do i do I need to
talk about well we had a lot of video
production and a lot more video
production than you saw me releasing in
part because for this new Aristotle
nikka McCain ethics class I have shot i
would say at this point something close
to 55 or 60 new core concept videos and
those have been for the people enrolled
in that class but i'm going to be
releasing them to the general public
pretty soon half-hour Hagel I got my six
video quoted done this month we managed
to finish up with the very first section
observing reason which is great because
I want to move into the next material I
did an some core concept videos on the
manalo gian we managed to go through not
every single chapter of the Mona Logan
but a good bit of it I did a doctor say
on the response video you know it's
important for me to start doing these I
had a video about reason I owe the
five-year reunion something that I'm you
know was surprised by be very happy
about and then videos from those two
talks that I mentioned the one on
azimoff the other one on an some that's
what went on during the month of May
we've got a lot of really cool stuff
coming up in the month of june we're
starting off with a talk in that that
monthly series on speculative fiction
and philosophy and the world creation
that it that the authors that we're
looking at are doing and this month we
are doing Frank Herbert's dune and we
probably will spend most of our time
just on that first book which is a dense
one by itself but i'll try to get in
some talk about some of the follow up
books in the series as well that is on
jun 9th at the brookfield public library
at 7pm if you're in the area and you
want to engage in a conversation about
some great sci-fi
and the philosophical themes involved
show up and you know we'll certainly
take any questions or engage in any
conversation then half hour hagel we
will be having our public Q&A on
Wednesday the fifteenth and that is at
five p.m. central time it's very
important that you note the time then
that we're in the central time zone
because sometimes people show up at the
wrong time and then they're very
disappointed that big lecture on the
eight tastes of food is going to be
wednesday june twenty second at the
whitefish bay library if you're if
you're coming to that you want to get
yourself a ticket for it because this is
a very big event we've got linked to
below you're definitely not going to
want to miss that if you're in the area
this is really one of the big events of
the year it's been a long time in
planning that is at 630pm on the
twenty-second and then if you're in the
area and you would like to go to a
conference on Aristotle an Aristotelian
ism or if you just like to poke your
head in I'm going to be doing a talk on
a cross iya due to anger how exactly
does that work for the Aristotle and
Aristotelian Aristotelian ISM conference
here at marquette university downtown
just blocks from where we live that is a
my talk will actually be on the
twenty-eighth of june at 3pm the
conference itself lasts from the 27th
through the 29th some pretty cool people
coming here to give talks I'm going to
be doing a lot of sort of you know
catching up with old friends and meeting
some new people and and engaging in a
lot of really great discussion about
about risk Italian ism so that's the
events coming up I do want to talk about
something else that isn't happening in
June although the planning for it might
be happening in June so as I mentioned
stoic on is happening in October and
it's going to be happening on the
fifteenth of October
in New York City I'm going to be there
doing a workshop of one and a half hour
workshop on anger and anger management
and what the stoics have to tell us
about our own anger other people's anger
anger in the culture how we can be less
angry people so if you're in New York
City you definitely want to come to that
and you don't just want to go to my talk
you want to go to as many of the talks
in that that conference is possible i'm
also going out to dinner as a
fundraising thing with with some of the
people who are attending the conference
and they're paying some sort of premium
and then they get to you no chit chat
with me afterwards about stoicism and
all sorts of other you know philosophy
related things so that that's a really
great idea but here's where the rest of
the the picture comes in so stoic week
itself international stoic week is that
Monday afterwards so the 17th all the
way to the next Sunday what we like to
see in stoicism today and in the modern
sort of neo stoic community is events
worldwide you know I do events wherever
I happen to be I did one here in
Milwaukee last year all sorts of you
know stomach meetups will have events
and so we want to see as much of that as
possible in order to contribute to that
on my part I am going to be devoting the
second half of my circuit tour to giving
talks about stoicism what is the circuit
tour while I'm glad you asked so i am
going to drive from here to New York
City and I'm going to be stopping off
along the way and where I stop depends
on who books me and who wants me to come
and give a talk and who is willing to
put me up I'm willing to do some of the
talks depending on the institutions for
free for some of the other institutions
that actually have budgets I would like
to see some sort of compensation you
know a little stipend but I'm going to
try to keep that as low as possible I am
looking for people to put
me up along the way so i don't have to
shell out a lot for hotel rooms because
this is a circuit or this is a speaking
tour i am going to be putting my you
know acumen and services at the disposal
of those who who invite me in so if its
schools i'll talk at a school if it's a
you know if it's a church if it's a
business organization whatever whatever
and whoever is willing to put me up and
bring me in to give a talk i will do
that along the way all the way out there
and then all the way back the ones on
the way back ordering stoic week so I
want it to be things that have to do
with stoicism but i'm game for talking
about other things on the way out I'll
do a video about that probably later
this month to talk a bit more about it
and get some information up but I'm
going to put a link below if you're
interested in this sort of thing you can
check out the link it's going to go to
our reason I Oh website where I'll have
information about the circuit or or you
can always just directly email me at
Greg at reason I Oh calm so that's a
really cool thing we'll see whether it
works or not this is a huge experiment
if you if you want it to be successful
then you might consider you know putting
in something on that and if this works
we're going to do other circuit tours as
well we'll do one going down south we'll
do one going out west we'll see about
all sorts of other possible tours of
that sort now another big thing that we
have coming up of course is the play-doh
symposium class that is beginning on the
19th of june and continuing through to
the 16th of july i'll put a link to the
video below i don't need to talk an
awful lot about it this is a not for
credit course there it's you know going
to be four weeks for fairly intensive
weeks we're going to go through one of
the greatest works of Western literature
one that I have been teaching for years
and years and years and really really
love you can learn more about that in
the video though I don't need to
tell you more about that in this what
else have we got going on in June well I
am continuing along with my executive
coaching and academic coaching some
philosophical counseling I don't foresee
doing a lot of tutoring during june but
you never know if you're interested in
any of those services go ahead and check
it out on our website or again you can
email me i'm going to get some more
blogging done this month definitely
going to be doing some more blogging in
part because there won't be at having to
do quite so much video work that the
aristotle videos really took a lot of
time got some collaborations going on so
a few things sort of in the air right
now right now i'm definitely going to be
doing a collaboration with Tom Ritchie
who does all sorts of cool you know
college prep courses I might be doing
something depending on his schedule with
Marcus mygda who have done two
interviews with in the past very cool
guy I have great conversations with him
I need to follow up so that's why it's
the only thing that's that's not
guaranteed I'm in conversations right
now with the partially examined life
people to begin doing some some other
collaborations with them but i'll tell
you more about when they get a bit more
solid and i've also been working with
the the guys over at the pocket stoic
app which is a cool thing to produce
some content for them more about that of
course when that comes out this month of
june i'm also going to be investing some
time and work in my curious courses i
have a lot of video content that just
needs to be you know have the exercises
associated with it create a few handouts
to to go along with it some links to
appropriate content so you're going to
be seeing some sort stuff come out this
month perhaps some Rilke stuff with
curious maybe some more play-doh stuff
maybe some epictetus maybe some
Aristotle I'm going to be loading all
those things in now last thing that I
should talk about a video content for
this month so
mention that I shot all these Aristotle
core concept videos on Nicomachean
ethics from books one all the way to
book ten this month and probably the
next month and probably the next one
after that I'm going to start releasing
that content so if you didn't take the
course and you didn't see the videos in
the course you'll have access to them
now not of course in the same sort of
structure that the people in the course
do or it's all available in in one you
know one page but you can you know
follow along with them and hopefully
you'll enjoy them got you know a quota
of six more half-hour Hagel videos to
put out this month by the way I should
always say if you want to support the
sort of work that I do one of the best
ways you can do that is by becoming a
patreon supporter on the half-hour Hagel
project because that's one of the most
intensive things that I do and that's
creating a digital resource a
comprehensive digital commentary on
Hegel's phenomenology that's going to be
out there for hopefully you know years
and maybe even generations to come got
some talk videos that will be recording
I'm not sure if I'll be able to record
the Aristotle marquette one but i'll
definitely be recording the a taste of
food the Frank Herbert one going to do
some personal videos as well because
I've had some some things that I've been
thinking about that I really wanted to
start shooting someone and I think I if
I have the time i'm going to do some
more of those dr. Sandler responds
because there's a lot of there's a lot
of issues that people keep bringing up
over and over and over again so keep an
eye out and maybe you'll see some of
those so let me close by saying you know
I hope you have a great month of June
ahead summer's here at least for those
of us in the northern hemisphere it's a
wonderful time many of you are out of
school which i'm sure you're enjoying so
there there's all of that and i will
finish by saying you know if you want to
get in touch with me about projects
collaborations best way to do that
speaking gigs best
to do that is to email me directly at
Greg at reason I Oh calm so great month
ahead hope you have a great month and I
will interact with you and in whatever
forms we connected